it was once a place of top secret
importance Bletchley Park where World
War II code Breakers decrypted enemy
ciphers and helped pave the way for an
Allied Victory now a symbolic location
for tackling the next Frontier
artificial intelligence and the
agreement to manage its as yet unknown
capabilities 28 countries including the
US and China have signed up to The
Bletchley declaration an attempt to
Kickstart a Global approach to manage
the very latest technology amid warnings
from Tech Giants that it presents the
greatest existential threat to humanity
echoed by the US vice president from AI
enabled cyber attacks at a scale beyond
anything we've seen before to AI
formulated bioweapons that could
endanger the lives of millions of people
while AI could pose significant dangers
to Life as we know it it also has the
potential to transform that for the
better including in medicine in
combating climate change and in
manufacturing the question for leaders
will be how to control and eradicate
those
dangers for the host prime minister
Rishi sunak it will be a test of his
pitch to place the UK at the heart of AI
governance despite the US's dominance in
the sector the people who are developing
the technology themselves have raised
some concerns about what might happen
how it might be used by Bad actors and I
want to take a lead in protecting the
British people an urgent call for
leaders to act before it's too late
Sonia Gago Al
jaer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer